bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
ce matin débat sur la mise en place des
35 heures à l'hôpital
un débat demandé ici au sénat par le
groupe centriste
alors vous le savez la mise en place des
35 heures à créer de vrais problèmes
d'organisation au sein des groupes
hospitaliers ainsi du fait des rtt deux
millions deux jours ont été accumulées
par les praticiens hospitaliers
par ailleurs sachez que françois
hollande s'est engagé à répondre aux
problèmes de sous-effectifs au sein des
hôpitaux
voilà tout de suite donc on se dirige
vers l'hémicycle l'ordre du jour appelle
le débat sur le bilan des 35 heures à
l'hôpital à la demande du groupe
udi uc et la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat monsieur jean arthuis
du bonheur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
des affaires sociales et de la santé
n'est chère collègue l'hôpital est au
coeur de notre système de santé sont
coûte 65 milliards par an est toujours
l'objet d'interrogations notamment à
l'occasion des projets de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
nous savons bien que les frais de
personnel
ils prennent une place prépondérante
c'est pour cette raison que le groupe
eut des é u c'est à souhaiter établir le
bilan des 35 heures à l'hôpital et plus
globalement il est peut être temps de
faire le point sur les 35 heures dans la
fonction publique
la situation est suffisamment grave pour
rompre avec les conventions de langage
habituels et sortir des clivages
traditionnels qui nous ont contourné
dans l'absence de décision et de
réformes structurelles
il est symptomatique que nous débattions
aujourd'hui des 35 heures à l'hôpital au
moment où le président de la république
entend réduire de 50 milliards les
dépenses publiques
au surplus nous devons avoir à l'esprit
que les frais de personnel représentent
entre 65 et 75 % du budget des hôpitaux
et des établissements médico sociaux
rien de comparable avec les autres
secteurs
c'est dans ce contexte exigeant que nous
tentons enfin d'évaluer les bienfaits
attendus est supposé de la grande
réforme mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement de lionel jospin dès son
arrivée aux affaires
partager le travail comme on partage un
gâteau pour que chacun trouve un emploi
sans doute aussi pour tirer profit des
gains de productivité ce faisant
nous mettons les projecteurs sur le
régime de travail des seuls agents de la
fonction publique hospitalière
c'est à dire un million cent cinquante
mille personnes sur un effectif global
de 6 millions de personnes employées
directement ou indirectement par les
institutions publiques
s'agissant de l'hôpital la situation
madame la ministre vous le savez bien
est alarmante
tant les dysfonctionnements se
multiplient si l'industriel numérique
ont vocation à libérer les hommes d'une
partie du temps qu'ils consacrent à leur
travail à proportion des avancées
technologiques et de l'amélioration de
la compétitivité qui en résulte il n'en
va pas de même dans le secteur de la
santé et de l'assistance aux personnes
la présence la disponibilité la tension
et la relation humaine n'ont rien de
commun avec les mécanismes qui prête la
matière le constat est aujourd'hui
aveuglant les agents des hôpitaux sont
en souffrance
le malaise profond affecte avec la même
acuité les établissements sanitaires
notamment les établissements accueillant
des personnes âgées dépendantes
la sécurité dans nombre de services est
en danger les plaintes les doléances se
multiplient de la part des résidents et
de leurs familles
faute de temps les agents espace le
rythme des toilettes corporelle et le
nettoiement des chambres devient chômeur
le patient voit sa condition largement
dégradée aurait-on oublié le facteur
humain l'heure est venue de prendre la
mesure des conséquences de l'utopie qui
a inspiré la réduction du temps de
travail
véritable pari intellectuelle destinés
aux secteurs concurrentiels pour lutter
contre le chômage
il est éclairant de rappeler que
certains économistes ce de
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques le fc eux
avait estimé qu'en réduisant la durée du
temps de travail
il deviendrait possible de créer deux
millions d'emplois
leurs travaux avait inspiré la
proposition phare des candidats
socialistes lors des élections
législatives de juin 1997
c'est donc la loi qui met fin à toute
démarche conventionnel convenons-en
paris démagogique puisque les salaires
ne subissent aucune correction à la
baisse
c'est travailler moins pour gagner
autant la prévision mirifiques a bien
vite été revues à la baisse
je me souviens à cet égard des propos
tenus par le directeur de l'ot fce le 7
janvier 1998 devant la commission
denquête créé au sénat à ma demande pour
mesurer les conséquences prévisibles de
la décision de réduire à 35 heures la
durée hebdomadaire du travail
voici ce que déclarait jean paul
fitoussi
lors de son audition je le cite en
elle-même l'idée est généreuse elle
revient à partager de façon beaucoup
plus équitable
le fardeau du chômage sans le réduire
globalement on sent percer dit il chez
les économistes de la fcpe qui ont
procédé à l'étude une pointe de regret
la loi des 35 heures est crédible parce
qu'elle est réaliste mais précisément
pour cela le partage du travail ne
décrit plus l'utopie d'une société
devenue si solidaire qu'elle fournit un
travail à chacun et à laquelle ils
avaient rêvé dans un précédent travail
en devenant loi
l'utopie devient réaliste mais elle
divise par presque 5 leurs espérances
400000 emplois au lieu des 2 millions
auxquels ils avaient rêvé
lors d'une précédente simulation dans
cet exercice les emplois publics
n'étaient pas visés il s'agissait
exclusivement
du secteur concurrentiel faisant fi de
tous les arguments économiques et
sociaux ignorant les enjeux de
compétitivité liés à la mondialisation
résultat les risques de délocalisation
d'activités et d'emploi n'ayant les
signes d'accélération de la
désindustrialisation la majorité de
l'époque a voté les 35 heures le
gouvernement tenant les promesses des
candidats en campagne c'est à son
honneur a promulgué sa loi faisant
naître l'espoir de réduire
significativement le faux marges
la suite est lâche et connu après une
baisse éphémère le chômage ne cesse de
progresser
la france se marginalise est les données
publiées hier soir ne font que confirmer
la tendance
mais revenons à 1998 dans un premier
temps suivant cela l'arbitrage du
ministre du travail de l'époque madame
martine aubry il n'était pas question
d'étendre le dispositif aux agents de la
sphère publique
il est vrai que les simulations utopiste
de la fcm comme je viens de le rappeler
n'avait pas pris en compte l'application
des 35 heures dans la sphère publique
c'est par décret d'août 2000 que la
réduction du temps de travail a été
étendue aux trois fonctions publiques
les effectifs ont rapidement progressé
passant de 4 millions huit cent trente
mille ans 98 à 5 millions trois cent
soixante mille fin 2011
la fonction publique hospitalière a
suivi cette tendance mais plus
rapidement aux mêmes dates le nombre
d'agents évolué de neuf cent trente
mille à un million cent trente mille
soit +21 5% depuis 2011 la progression
s'est maintenue des l'extension des 35
heures
les effectifs avaient bondi et les
charges personnelles progresser
significativement sur le terrain les
réponses ont été diverses selon les
cultures locales et la nature du
dialogue social dans le centre
hospitalier de château-gontier en
mayenne que je connais bien parce que
jean préside le conseil d'administration
depuis quelques années déjà
dans ce centre hospitalier le directeur
et les représentants du personnel
avaient fait preuve d'un réalisme
responsable le gouvernement vous vous en
souvenez avait alloué un supplément de
ressources de 5% et dans ces conditions
les recrutements ont été régulée à cette
hauteur ce qui a nécessité la
mobilisation de toutes les marges de
progression pour économiser 5 à 6 % du
budget au même moment
convenons-en le gel implicite des
salaires discrètement imposés a permis
de tenir relativement le cap dans
l'organisation du travail
il n'a pas été possible de réduire la
durée quotidienne du temps de travail
dans la proportion de 39 à 35
les buteurs sont devenus 7h45 afin de
permettre la transmission des
informations entre les équipes de
soignants pour faire l'état sur la
situation des malades pris en charge ce
dispositif a donc abouti à la
multiplication des journées de rtt
créant des perturbations dans les
services du fait de la succession des
interlocuteurs au détriment des
personnes hospitalisées et des agents
eux-mêmes dont les plannings bien
souvent sont totalement bouleversées et
plus cohérent au delà des hôpitaux dans
les maisons de retraite et les ehpad des
établissements habilités à accueillir
des personnes âgées dépendantes dans les
établissements sanitaires relevant de
l'uniopss opérateurs de l'état
opérateurs des départements accueillant
des personnes handicapées ou des
personnes âgées dans les foyers
d'hébergement de jeunes pris en charge
par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
les prix de journée ont atteint des
niveaux difficilement supportable par
les pensionnaires comme par leur famille
corrélativement le recours aux finances
publiques s'est considérablement alourdi
les gestionnaires de ces établissements
tente bien sûr de contenir la masse
salariale c'est ainsi que les contrats
précaires se multiplient emplois
d'avenir et contrats jeunes une sorte de
dessous fonction publique dont souffrent
nombre de jeunes
à défaut de réformer le statut de la
fonction publique où certaines
conventions collectives je pense à
celles de l'uniopss et bien un espace de
précarité s'est largement développé dans
les établissements du secteur sanitaire
face aux impératifs de maîtrise des
dépenses
les pressions se font vives pour réduire
le nombre de journées de rtt
il en résulte un climat de tension un
climat d'incompréhension et de stress si
tous les droits acquis au titre des rtt
madame la ministre des millions d'heures
étaient comptabilisés dans les dettes
des établissements nombre de ceux ci
seraient déficitaires ou plus encore
déficitaire qu'ils ne le sont en
apparence
autrement dit la réalité des charges et
masqués parce que les provisions qui
devrait être constituée à la fin des
exercices ne sont pas transcrite dans
les bilans
l'utopie des 35 heures n'a en aucune
façon répondu à l'objectif de ses
concepteurs dans le secteur marchand la
désindustrialisation s'est poursuivie
les délocalisations d'activités et
d'emplois se sont accélérées et le
chômage de masse explosent
je les dis les données publiées hier
soir confirme malheureusement cette
tendance non prévu à l'origine
son extension à la fonction publique
incontestablement créer des emplois sans
doute plus de 650000 en tenant compte
des effectifs des opérateurs de l'état
et des opérateurs des départements dans
le secteur médico social
mais ceci n'a fait qu'aggraver la dérive
budgétaire faute à mes yeux accablante
et comble de l'hypocrisie politique pire
les conditions de travail en milieu
hospitalier et dans les établissements
médico sociaux
se sont dégradées au point de mettre en
péril la sécurité et le respect dû aux
personnes
à mes yeux c'est un fiasco l'heure est
venue pour le gouvernement de sortir
enfin du déni de réalité
nous avons bien compris que nous avons
le devoir impératif de réduire de 50
milliards d'euros le montant des
dépenses publiques
nous devons également maintenir au
meilleur niveau la qualité des soins
dans les hôpitaux comme celui de
l'accueil dans les établissements
sanitaires et sociaux
dès lors les 35 heures ne peuvent rester
en l'état c'est une évidence à l'hôpital
mais plus globalement la question doit
être posée pour l'ensemble de la
fonction publique fonction publique
territoriale fonction publique d'état
l'enjeu global
madame la ministre peut être évalué à
une vingtaine de milliards d'euros
le diagnostic est en pause et je
souhaite que nous puissions renoncer au
dogmatisme habituel faire taire l'esprit
partisan et avancer courageusement vers
les réformes structurelles qui
conditionne le redressement de la france
sans remise en cause des 35 heures
les 50 milliards d'économies annoncées
par le président de la république sont
un mirage avant de conclure je veut
interroger le gouvernement
à propos de son projet de loi sur
l'autonomie que vous avez qualifié
madame de grand chantier du quinquennat
dont l'examen et le vote sont annoncées
pour la fin de l'année 2014
nous le savons bien les attentes sont
vives et légitime pour y répondre
de nouveaux moyens vont devoir être
mobilisés combien de milliards
quel plan de financement pour cette
nouvelle avancée tendant à répondre aux
attentes des personnes âgées dépendantes
l'extension des 35 heures dans la
fonction publique hospitalière madame
est un échec
il convient donc d'y porter remède sans
plus attendre
le retour aux 39 heures ne peut plus
être différé les modalités doivent faire
l'objet de dialogue et de négociation
c'est désormais une affaire de lucidité
et de courage pour les responsables
politiques comme pour les partenaires
sociaux tu dois aussi penser à ceux qui
n'ont pas de travail
l'utopie l'utopie c'est l'idée que les
35 heures pouvait résoudre le problème
du chômage et le mirage le mirage c'est
de croire que nous pourrons réduire de
50 milliards les dépenses publiques sans
remettre en cause
l'utopie que constituent les 35 heures
est bien l'utopie est le mirage ne
peuvent plus longtemps masqué ce qui ne
tarderait pas à s'apparenter à une
lâcheté politique
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite du débat la parole est à madame
catherine génisson pour le groupe
socialiste
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
entendu le réquisitoire assises dont le
réquisitoire incisif concernant
l'application des 35 heures à l'hôpital
de notre collègue jean arthuis et mes
chers collègues vous comprendrez que je
ne partage pas le constat mais avant
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet je
souhaite porter témoignage du
fonctionnement de l'hôpital public comme
accompagnantes récente d'une personne
soyez je vais souligné la compétence
professionnelles associées à des
conditions d'accueil de grande qualité
de l'ensemble des personnels temps
médicaux que paramédicaux et se bat à
peu à l'encontre du constat un peu
délétère que vous avez fait mon cher
collègue mais je veux aussi souligner
leur demande très forte de
reconnaissance et celle de retrouver les
repères de leur parcours professionnel
à l'intérieur de la communauté
hospitalière il effectivement important
d'agir et c'est l'une des priorités de
la loi de santé publique
traiter du sujet de l'application des 35
heures à l'hôpital et je m'en tiendrai à
ce sujet suppose de dissocier les
médecins les médecins du personnel
paramédical et administratif
la réduction du temps de travail résulte
de deux protocoles d'accord celui du 27
septembre 2001 qui concerne la fonction
publique hospitalière à celui de 22
octobre qui concerne les personnels
médicaux pour les personnels pas ma
paramédicaux il s'est agit le plus
souvent de réduire le poste de travail à
7h45 didou 7h30 avec l'attribution de
quinze jours de repos compensateur
parents intégrés dans les cycles de
travail
il était souhaitée de rechercher des
gains en terme de nationalisation
d'organisation des soins
force est de constater que cette mise en
place de la réduction du temps de
travail n'a pas été évidente à se
concrétiser
j'avais participé fin 2002 début 2003 à
une mission parlementaire présidée par
notre collègue maire rené couanau sur le
sujet de l'organisation interne des
hôpitaux
et je dois reconnaître que très souvent
les personnels hospitaliers rencontre et
exprimer leurs difficultés à mettre en
place ce nouveau dispositif
d'organisation du travail de réseau me
semble-t-il
face à ce constat l'inadéquation entre
les besoins y compris quand les
créations de postes exister et la
demande et la demande dès lors que les
écoles d'infirmières en particulier ne
formait pas le nombre de personnels
nécessaires
la deuxième raison est peut être plus
importante
une demande d'application rapide de la
réforme n'a pas permis l'application
qualitative qui aurait dû après une
évaluation fine du fonctionnement d'un
service permettre de faire des
propositions qui prenait en compte une
nécessaire complémentarité entre les
différents professionnels
trop souvent la réduction du temps de
travail a été appliquée par filières
professionnelles et cela a pu engendrer
des dysfonctionnements pour les
personnels médicaux la mise en place de
la réduction du temps de travail s'est
fait de façon concomitante à la
transcription de la directive européenne
relative à leur temps de travail dans le
cadre de la mise en place de la
réduction du temps de travail depuis
2002 les praticiens bénéficient d'une
réduction forfaitaire de la durée
annuelle de travail de vingt jours ils
peuvent ouvrir un compte épargne temps
il y affecter conjugaux jours de
réduction du temps de travail n'ont pris
ou jours de compensation des plages de
temps de travail additionnelle non
indemnisé en effet et c'est la
transposition de la directive européenne
a mis en place un certain nombre de
dispositions comptabiliser les gardes
comme temps de travail effectif c'est ça
je crois que c'est très important pour
la prise en coûte compte du parcours
professionnel des praticiens
hospitaliers créé la dignité de
suggestions versée pour chaque période
de garde intégré dans des obligations de
service recourir à du temps de travail
additionnelle sur la base du volontariat
confirmer l'obligation de repos
quotidien ou 11 heures que c'est que
tifa période de 24 heures et je crois
que ça c'est très important pour avoir
longtemps exercé comme praticiens
hospitaliers anesthésistes dans un
centre hospitalier il était évident que
après 48 heures de garde
on avait été quasiment debout tout le
temps il était quand même dangereux de
recommencer son poste de travail
après le week-end à 8 heures du matin
est considéré le temps de travail
accompli durant les périodes d'astreinte
à domicile comme du temps de travail
effectif et indemniser forfaitairement
est la principale modification du temps
de travail des médecins à l'hôpital ces
dernières années et donc moi l'art la
mise en place de la réduction du temps
de travail que l'intégration des gardes
en ce temps de travail associée je viens
de le souligner a l'obligation de repos
quotidien et à l'interdiction de prendre
de façon cumulative des gardes de suite
la mise en place de la réduction du
temps de travail a conduit à mettre en
place de nouveaux outils de gestion
comme les comptes épargne temps que je
viens d'évoquer et dont le format s'est
adapté au fil du temps le compte épargne
temps a été créé pour permettre aux
agents de la fonction publique
hospitalière d'y porter une partie des
jours de congés annuels n'ont pris ainsi
qu'une partie des jours accordé non pris
au titre de la réduction du temps de
travail ainsi que des heures
supplémentaires non récupérées et non
indemnisées
le compte épargne temps a également été
créé pour les personnels médicaux je
viens de l'évoquer il faut acter que les
personnels paramédicaux ont peu recours
aux comptes épargne temps
les bilans successifs de l'application
des 35 heures ont montré la nécessité de
travailler sur l'accumulation dix jours
de congés et des jours de rtt non qu'on
sait mais il a fallu adapter la réforme
tout cela pour aboutir au décret du 6
décembre 2012 qui prévoit notamment
qu'un maximum de dix jours peut être
intégré chaque année dans le compte
épargne temps avec un plafond maximal de
60 jours n'est que ce compte épargne
temps à une durée illimitée
aujourd'hui qu'elle constate pouvons
nous faire l'application des 35 heures
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
et j'allais dire unanime en publicité
quelles que soient les personnels
concernés médicaux paramédicaux
administratifs
pour autant on ne peut ignorer les
tensions qui existent en particulier au
regard de l'intensification des rythmes
de travail et il y a des causes
endogènes à l'hôpital mais aussi externe
parmi les causes endogènes on peut citer
la nécessité d'adapter de façon
permanente pour les personnels leur
travail au regard des progrès de la
médecine la nécessité d'adapter
d'adaptation pour répondre aux
changements d'organisation du travail à
l'hôpital tels que le développement de
la charge obligatoire au globull à
thouars pardon l'hôpital de jour
l'hôpital de semaine par exemple et la
demande qui est faite à l'ensemble des
personnels de travailler sur tous les
postes de travail matin après midi nuit
quand auparavant cette organisation de
travail se déclinent les principalement
dans les services de soins intensifs
cette exigence d'organisation du travail
est favorable à la prise en charge de la
vue du patient qu'en ces temps de vie
sont différents le matin l'après-midi la
nuit mais ce mode d'organisation
entraîne une pénibilité accrue pour le
personnel quand auparavant les postes de
jour et de nuit étaient dissocier les
causes des tensions sont aussi externes
à l'hôpital en effet si celui ci est
toujours le recours quand il ya
défaillance de l'organisation du système
de santé
il lui est difficile d'en absorber les
conséquences en permanence et je ne
prendrai que l'exemple du sujet de la
permanence des soins
le constat des difficultés
d'organisation du système libéral
libéral conduit à l'augmentation
permanente de la fréquentation des
services d'argent ce qui par ailleurs on
en avale les difficultés à faire
hospitaliser les patients dans les
services qu'on sait derniers sont
souvent sur souvent de plus en plus
spécialisés vous avez d'ailleurs fait
des propositions en la matière madame la
ministre proposant qu'il y est une
personne qui régule les entrées dans les
services à partir des urgences de nos
patients madame la ministre vous
travaillez bien sûr activement à trouver
des solutions à ces sujets et en
particulier à la regarder réorganisation
de la médecine de premier recours face
au co attention des conditions de
travail à l'hôpital résultant de
problèmes de disponibilité des
personnels
il est important d'en faire un
diagnostic fin entre d'une part le moc
structurale de personnel à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
conséquence d'organiser de
réorganisation lourde
je dois dire que depuis dix ans
on a subi et d'autre part l'obligation
d'assumer des dysfonctionnements de
l'organisation de notre système de santé
et j'évoquais à l'instant le sujet de la
permanence des soins
au nom de mon groupe politique je veux
exprimer notre attachement à
l'application des 35 heures dans la
fonction publique hospitalière
tout en reconnaissant les réelles
difficultés d'application lors de leur
mise en place et j'ai envie de dire
qu'aujourd'hui les 35 heures ne sont
plus le sujet s'il ya bien le travail
oit sont légitimes
c'est bien la fonction publique
hospitalière quand en particulier elle
constitue l'une des réponses à la
pénibilité tant physique que
psychologique de l'ensemble des métiers
hospitalier aujourd'hui nous avons
immobilisé sur la réorganisation du
soins primaires sur la démocratie
sanitaire sur l'obligation l'obligation
de redonner sens cohérence au service
public hospitalier d'adapter la
gouvernance à l'hôpital ayant commis
avec notre collègue alain milon un
rapport sur le sujet et dès qu'on pense
des coopérations entre professionnels de
santé
il nous semble que nous pourrions
travailler à des propositions qui
permettrait entre autres de valoriser la
profession socle en développant les
possibilités d'évolution de carrière de
soins les infirmières par exemple
pourrait avoir la possibilité à côté de
promotion dans la carrière
administrative de cadres évoluer dans la
carrière soins et peut-être
pourrions-nous définir des infirmières
cliniciennes ses priorités madame la
ministre aux solutions desquels vous
travaillez dans le cas de la préparation
du projet de loi de santé publique sont
attendus avec intérêt et nous savons
pouvoir compter sur votre engagement
votre détermination madame ministre
nous vous en remercions et nous serons à
votre côté merci ma chère collègue la
parole est à madame aline archimbaud
pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues je ne suivrai pas moi
non plus le réquisitoire que nous venons
d'entendre contre les 35 heures à
l'hôpital
les écologistes sont et ont toujours été
pour la réduction du temps de travail
nous préconisons d'ailleurs une
négociation sociale urgente sur
réduction du temps de travail tout au
long de la vie avec comme objectif
d'encourager les employeurs et les
salariés allaient avancer sur cette
question
l'hôpital est l'un des lieux de travail
où cette réforme peut prendre tout son
sens la charge physique émotionnel des
personnes qui travaillent quel que soit
leur poste est énorme
les horaires ils sont atypiques
évidemment car les patients doivent
faire l'objet d'une attention continue
il ne faut de surcroît jamais baisser la
garde sur la qualité de son travail qui
est directement corrélé à la qualité de
l'accueil de l' écoute et des soins
apportés aux patients ces trois
variables ayant un impact direct sur
leur état de santé aussi la réforme des
35 heures qui est une des avancées
sociales majeures du gouvernement de
lionel jospin
avait-elle un sens particulier à
l'hôpital cette réduction du temps de
travail a été mise en oeuvre sur la base
de deux protocoles
le premier datant du 27 septembre 2001
en ce qui concerne les personnels non
médicaux et le second du 22 octobre 2001
en ce qui concerne les personnels
médicaux le protocole dédié aux
personnels non médicaux proposait
notamment d'améliorer les organisations
de travail les conditions de vie au
travail avec une durée hebdomadaire
moyenne de 35 heures est de 32 heures 30
pour les personnels de nuit des heures
supplémentaires limitée à 20 puis et 15
puis 10 par mois
il prévoyait aussi la création de 45
mille emplois non médicaux répartis
entre le secteur sanitaire 37000 le
secteur social et médico-social du mil
ensuite le protocole concernant les
personnels médicaux proposent-elles
financement de l'intégration des gardes
dans le temps effectif de travail la
rémunération d'une partie des plages
additionnel la création de 3500 emplois
médicaux ce qui correspondait à un
chiffre
réaliste compte tenu des capacités de
recrutement mais qui nécessite elle a
aussi un effort de rationalisation dans
l'utilisation du temps médical par la
suite un contrat d'assouplissement a été
conclu en janvier 2003 introduisant la
possibilité de payer les jours de congés
non pris
du fait de la montée en charge de la rtt
et qui a élargit également les
conditions d'utilisation des comptes
épargne temps en énumérant ses
conséquences de la réforme on mesure
l'avancée sociale qu'elle a constitué
pour tous les personnels hospitaliers
mais il faut avouer en effet que tout
n'a pas été aussi simple ni aussi fluide
de fait les créations d'emplois non
médicaux n'ont pu être effective dès
janvier 2002 elles se sont étalés du
point de vue des autorisations notifié
aux établissements entre 2002 et 2004 et
a cédé l'es7 ajouté selon les
établissements selon les régions un laps
de temps plus ou moins importants pour
le recrutement
selon le contexte de pénurie des
personnels et par ailleurs ils sentent
le nombre des emplois créés et est
inférieur aux chiffres initialement
prévue au lieu de 37 mille emplois non
médicaux supplémentaires prévus dans le
secteur sanitaire
seuls 35 milles par exemple ont été
créés et par ailleurs le recrutement des
3500 postes médicaux prévus pour combler
les rtt des professionnels de santé
là encore la totalité de ces postes n'a
pas été pourvus faute de candidats et
surtout faute de crédits accordés aux
établissements pour embaucher compenser
l'effet de la mesure de toute manière la
cour des comptes indique dans son
rapport de mai 2006 sur les personnels
des établissements publics de santé que
même les postes annoncées ne suffisait
déjà pas à compenser la baisse du temps
de travail
alors au delà des créations d'emplois
les 35 heures couplée avec une maîtrise
des effectifs était supposée amener les
services effectués des gains de
productivité pour compenser la perte de
volume horaire en réduisant par exemple
les chevauchements des clips en mettant
en commun les moyens
au lieu de cela la réforme a débouché
c'est vrai sur une dégradation du
service public à l'hôpital
pour limiter les dégâts et assurer la
continuité du service public
un certain nombre de personnels
principalement les médecins ont dû
repousser la prise de rtt
entre 2002 et 2012 ce sont ainsi plus de
2 millions d'heures de rtt qui ont été
stockés or les retraités ne peuvent être
prises que dans un délai maximum de dix
ans et en 2012 a donc été laissé le
choix aux personnes concernées de se
voir payer certes été de les convertir
en points retraite ou de prendre des
congés ce qui en effet a engendré un
surcoût pour les hôpitaux de près de 600
millions d'euros
les hôpitaux n'ayant pas tous
suffisamment provisionné pour financer
ses rtt retardé
cela a créé des problèmes budgétaires
c'est un certain nombre d'entre eux en
2012 les comptes épargne temps en
conséquence été modifié de façon à ce
que la possibilité de stocker des congés
soit réduite
alors au final quel bilan tirer de la
mise en oeuvre des 35 heures dans les
hôpitaux publics
celui que l'idée était bonne et
salvatrice mais que sa mise en oeuvre
forcément complexe a connu les failles
les difficultés parfois importantes que
nous devons examiner dont nous devons
tirer des leçons rapidement et on en
tire également donc des des propositions
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il est inutile
nous semble-t-il aux gouvernements qui
se sont succédé depuis de se rejeter la
faute
l'ondam insuffisant du plfss successifs
le poids des déficits des comptes
sociaux sont par exemple également des
variables importantes qui ont
complexifié fortement l'application de
la réforme
alors pour nous la mise en place des 35
heures à l'hôpital n'était ni une utopie
ni un objectif démagogique
en effet sa mise en oeuvre a rencontré
de graves difficultés de mise en place
devant lesquelles nous sommes nous
pensons que les débats que nous aurons
prochainement lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de santé publique nous
permettront d'intégrer cette question à
d'autres questions dans ce sujet plus
vaste
d'une réforme du système de la santé
publique nous verrons comment articuler
par exemple cette question et cet
objectif qui doit perdurer des 35 heures
la réduction du temps de travail à la
façon de réduire les déficits de
l'assurance maladie de lutter contre les
inégalités dans l'accès au soin à la
santé de deux places et plus au coeur de
notre politique des systèmes de
prévention d'améliorer plus plus plus
généralement le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital public tout cela en
développant la démocratie sanitaire nous
aurons donc l'occasion de nous pencher
plus longuement à nouveau dans un sujet
beaucoup plus vaste sur cette question
de des 35 heures à l'hôpital je vous
remercie
merci madame la parole est au président
gérard larcher pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président un ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
mes chers collègues voudrais d'abord
remercier le groupe de l'union centriste
udi d'avoir permis ce débat est tout
particulièrement jean arthuis car elle
me paraît important au bout de dix
années que nous fassions le point ici
sans fard et sans mode apparence sur le
bilan le bilan d'une mise en place qui a
profondément bouleversé l'hôpital public
tout comme d'ailleurs la réforme du
temps de travail à bouleverser
profondément j'allais dire à certain
nombre d' équilibre dans notre pays
au point d'être un des facteurs pas le
seul de la perte de compétitivité
je voudrais simplement qu'on réfléchisse
sur un tout autre sujet qu'en 2004 la
filière agroalimentaire dans notre pays
faisait de notre pays le premier pays en
europe que nous serons bientôt le
quatrième derrière l'allemagne les
pays-bas et bientôt l'italie et que ces
réalités là il va bien falloir que nous
les prenions à bras le corps au delà des
choix idéologiques les uns ou des autres
car il s'agit de l'avenir de notre pays
mais revenons à l'hôpital
plus de dix ans après sa mise en place
cette loi sur les 35 heures et cette
mise en place à l'hôpital ont
profondément modifié la gestion du temps
de travail et tout particulièrement
c'est le point le plus important
l'organisation des soins ces impacts
sont d'autant plus forts qu'ils sont
intervenus dans un contexte hospitalier
caractérisé par une évolution forte des
modes de prise en charge un ondam
hospitalier faible une pénurie
d'infirmiers diplômés d'état à partir de
2008 et une pénurie de médecins
hospitaliers dans certaines spécialités
quels sont donc ces impacts majeurs
constatés pour les établissements
hospitaliers médicaux sociaux et quelles
pourraient être les pistes d'évolution
tout d'abord impact des 35 heures à
l'hôpital
les impacts sociaux je le dis
d'apparence positif en terme d'
avantages individuels et j'allais dire
de paix sociale les 35 heures ont
procuré des avantages individuels
certain en termes de jours de
récupération d'équilibré entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle
ils ont été un levier d'une certaine
tranquillité sociale est l'occasion
quand ils ont été conduits une assez
large concertation à l'intérieur des
établissements mais mais la loi a fait
de la durée du temps de travail le coeur
des discussions au détriment de
l'aménagement et de l'organisation du
temps de travail avec des accords il
n'est que de lire un certain nombre de
rapports avec des accords pro souvent
déséquilibré par souci de tranquillité
sociale ou du fait d'enjeux politiques
locaux faute une révision suffisante des
organisations du travail second les
impacts qui me paraît majeur et lui
négatif est sur la continuité du service
public à l'hôpital depuis 2002 et je
demande que chacun réfléchisse et
regarde dans son territoire
les fermetures de lui se sont
généralisés pendant les congés d'été
ça c'est une réalité concrète les
amplitudes horaires de travail ont
diminué
faute de recrutement à la hauteur des
besoins voilà la réalité
dès lors la continuité les organisations
est en fait utilisée comme variable
d'ajustement
les 35 heures ont accentué les
divergences d'organisation entre les
établissements et j'y reviendrai dans
quelques propositions dans les
établissements ayant accordé de
nombreuses rtt le temps de travail a été
arithmétiquement réduit sans pour autant
la plupart du temps que les
organisations du travail et jirau lien
ne soit réellement modifié à activité
constante la création de postes médicaux
et non médicaux a été alors insuffisante
pour compenser la baisse du temps de
travail liées au passage à 35 heures
l'un des exemples les plus frappants
frappant des effets organise chez un psy
organisationnelles des 35 heures et
pardonnez moi au travers du prisme du
cadre de santé dans un hôpital qui est
au fond la principale victime des 35
heures plongez noyé dans les plannings
les cadres de santé ne sont plus perçus
que comme des gestionnaires déconcentrés
des temps de travail et non comme des
animateurs des unités de soins
quelle est leur fonction essentielle ils
doivent gérer les effets les 35 heures
aussi sur la mentalité les agents en
ajustant les organisations des temps de
travail des soins des parcours de soins
ainsi que de ses modes managériaux
pour répondre à ces évolutions ils
doivent tenir compte du changement de
paradigme à l'hôpital qui veut que le
temps individuelle prime dorénavant sur
le temps collectifs et puis parlons
finances ceci a été évoquée par ma
collègue création de 35000 postes non
médicaux 3500 postes médicaux
ce partage du temps de travail s'est
traduit en fait par un alourdissement
sans précédent de la masse salariale des
établissements la réduction du temps de
travail a créé des charges financières
de gestion des jours de rtt
et si la durée du travail de nuit ramené
à 32 heures par semaine pour le secteur
public est un élément d'attractivité
certains
son coût est élevé pour les
établissements mais ceci a été évoqué le
cumul des rtt a généré un stock de
compte épargne temps très important
entre 2002 et 2012 2 millions d'heures
stocker or ces deux millions d'heures
devant être prise au plus tard en 2012
les hôpitaux on fait payer une grande
partie de ces jours stockés avec assure
coûts de 600 millions d'euros pour les
finances hospitalière voilà la réalité
enfin le recours à l'intérim paramédical
qui certes a tendance à diminuer
ces derniers mois mais le recours à
l'intérim médical qui lui augmente et si
je prends ce qui est versé aux sociétés
d'intérim les chiffres 2011 plus aux
rémunérations directes des contractuels
qui sont des intérimaires ses 767
millions d'euros cette diminution du
temps de travail censé inciter les
établissements à mieux maîtriser leurs
effectifs et à réaliser des gains de
productivité ne s'est pas réellement
concrétiser aux conséquences financières
s'est donc ajouté une dégradation des
conditions d'exercice du service public
à l'hôpital et un bouleversement du
rapport des professionnels de la valeur
travail
alors quelles évolutions paraît
souhaitable
je n'entrerai pas ce matin dans le débat
sur la question du temps de travail mais
c'est un débat essentiel et qui dépasse
la seule fonction publique hospitalière
la seule fonction publique il est posé
pour tout le pays il s'agit d'abord me
semble-t-il et c'est une responsabilité
un homme la ministre que vous avez que
les agences on est de soutenir les
établissements dans la révision de leurs
accords locaux afin de rétablir un
certain nombre d'écrits budgétaire
nombre d'établissements aux procédés ou
sont en train de procéder à la révision
de leurs accords locaux certains étant
très généreux ces démarches doivent être
soutenues par les pouvoirs publics
elles sont difficiles parfois
impopulaires
le redressement l'évidence hospitalière
objectif affiché par le gouvernement est
aussi à cette condition et il est
essentiel que ce ne soit pas par une
initialisation plan national mais bien
au niveau de chaque territoire avec une
coordination entre les établissements
il faut aussi recentrer les processus
organisationnels autour de la prise en
charge du patient
depuis 12 ans on planifie le temps de
travail et ensuite on planifie des
prestations de prise en charge
ensuite il faut recentrer le processus
organisationnels autour du
et remettre les processus de prise en
charge au coeur de ses préoccupations le
coeur du procès ce doit être le malade
et ça doit être le coeur des décisions
que nous prenons
il faut ainsi évaluer les organisations
requise les prestations de soins
réalisés et planifier les temps de
travail qui vont permettre de les
réaliser
l'enjeu est de rapprocher aussi au
maximum les organisations du travail du
personnel médical et du personnel non
médical au sein de chaque établissement
enfin il me semble important d'utiliser
l'annualisation du temps de travail pour
mettre en place ce qui n'existe pas une
politique à destination des seniors
alors qu'il n'existe pas aujourd'hui de
politiques spécifiques pour les seniors
travaillant à l'hôpital
l'annualisation du temps de travail doit
être utilisé comme un levier
d'accompagnement de population soignante
dans la troisième phase de leur vie
professionnelle
elle doit permettre de développer une
politique managériale des seniors un
cumul des comptes épargne temps sur les
trois dernières années pourrait par
ailleurs permettre un départ progressif
à la retraite et agir sur la pénibilité
et permettre le transfert de compétences
vers deux plus jeunes professionnels
enfin il faut revoir les organisations
hospitalières dans le cadre du service
public territorial de santé les
démarches de renégociation des accords
locaux doivent être conduites dans un
cadre territorial dans lequel les
hôpitaux d'un même territoire définirait
ensemble de nouvelles règles et ne
nouvelle organisation comment
voulez-vous parler de groupement de
coopération sanitaire de communautés
hospitalières de territoire
si il n'y a pas une certaine logique
d'organisation qui permettent la
continuité
enfin je le dis il va falloir simplifiée
et j'allais dire puisque le mouiller à
la mode créé un choc de simplification
de la réglementation du temps de travail
un règlement du sentation du temps de
travail et vous le savez complexe
abondant et je n'évoque pas les débats
que nous avons tous eu sur l'étang dhabi
de déshabillage de passation de
consignes toutes ces réalités
on en a oublié pourquoi c'était faire
tout cela il est capital que les acteurs
du terrain bénéficie de plus de
souplesse et d'autonomie pour gérer le
temps de travail des personnels médicaux
et non médicaux afin de s'adapter aux
réalités territoriales et aux besoins
réels des organisations voilà pourquoi
cette simplification doit s'accompagner
aussi d'un système d'information
performant qui réduit ce que j'appelle
aussi la pénibilité entre guillemets
d'application des 35 heures enfin c'est
un point essentiel
et si on veut faire
j'allais dire de ce sujet un sujet
positif il faut qu'on réinvente ce qui
n'existe que trop peu à l'hôpital public
le management des personnels c'est un
point me semble-t-il tout à fait
essentiel au coeur de la stratégie des
établissements publics et l'enjeu et la
mise en place d'une gestion des
ressources humaines plus ouvert plus
responsabilisante basée sur l'éthique
des pratiques professionnelles et plus
intégrée et j'y reviens au territoire
alors je vous le dis madame la ministre
il va falloir repenser le statut de
l'hôpital ce statut de l'hôpital pour
lui permettre réactivité capacité
d'adaptation aux enjeux de santé
publique aux réalités territoriales
cette évolution pour à la fois rassurer
les professionnels mais en même temps
donner les moyens aux hôpitaux de mettre
en place des organisations de travail
modernes adaptés aux besoins des
patients à leurs responsabilités et
territoriales à l'émergence de plus en
plus grande de l'hospitalisation à
domicile et des réalités de la
prévention il faut donc une autonomie
des acteurs un assouplissement et
simplification de la réglementation
voilà quelques mots clés me semble-t-il
pour l'avenir de l'hôpital public
mais je voudrais leur dire car j'étais à
l'époque président d'une grande
fédération des hôpitaux publics au
moment où j'ai rencontré et débattu avec
à l'époque madame aubry
et monsieur kouchner de ce dossier je
pense qu'on a affaibli l'hôpital public
de manière
j'allais dire extrêmement forte en
mettant en place des 35 heures de cette
manière
l hôpital public qu'on réfléchisse sur
le temps mais sur les organisations me
paraît utile et je pense qu'il ya eu une
partie du débat qui n'était pas inutile
mais en même temps on a alourdi
considérablement considérablement la
facture d'un système de santé qu'on a
mis en partie en péril et notamment dans
la continuité des soins
eh bien je pense que l'hôpital doit
continuer à s'adapter a évolué et qu'on
ne pourra pas avoir des plateaux
techniques partout qu'on ne pourra pas
avoir des professionnels partout mais il
y à un sujet comment on répond avec
qualité et égalité aux besoins de santé
de tous nos compatriotes ça c'est un
enjeu pour le parlement et en même temps
l'enjeu posée par jean arthuis tout à
l'heure comment fait-on alors que nous
savons qu'il va falloir que nous
trouvions 50 milliards d'économies de la
dépense publique que cette réalité là
elle est incontournable au point
d'ailleurs que l'autorité européenne
s'interroge sur notre capacité à revenir
ce qui n'aurait dû être qu'une barrière
maximum 3 % et qu'il aurait d'ailleurs
dû jamais dû exister sans doute pour
nous éviter les tentations et bien la
dimension des dépenses de santé
n'échappera pas et si nous voulons
répondre autrement que par la pénurie ou
par le faux semblant
il va falloir qu'on accepte de revoir
notre système d'organisation à l'hôpital
et notre système d'organisation passe
aussi par une capacité à revoir le temps
de travail
ceux ci possèdent une manière
imaginative qui ne soient pas contraints
qu'ils soient le fruit de négociations
c'est ce à quoi nous sommes appelés car
sinon les réveils seront douloureux et
se feront sur le dos de la réponse de
santé pour l'ensemble des français
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole est à monsieur jean
marie bockel pour le groupe udi uc
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
si le bilan des 35 heures est
globalement décevant ou en négatif à
l'hôpital il est en effet extrêmement
préoccupant pour c'est pour cela que
jean arthuis et le groupe u10 us et on
demandait ce débat parce que regard de
la réduction du temps de travail
il ya en effet une spécificité d'hôpital
les 35 heures lui en coûter cher trop
cher à tous égards début 2012 le
gouvernement de l'époque a mis en place
un plan d'apurement échelonné sur quatre
ans soit en 2014 à mi parcours un bilan
d'étape également à cet égard s'imposer
et la première chose qui frappe quand on
aborde cette question c'est le vide
mes chers collègues tous les
collaborateurs qui nous ont aidés qui
vous ont aidé à préparer ce débat pour
vous le dire il est très difficile de
trouver de la documentation sur le bilan
en 2014 des 35 heures à l'hôpital
on peut se demander si face à l'ampleur
du problème
une sorte de tabou ne s'est pas
constitué d'abord de quel problème
parle-t-on pas du problème des 35 heures
en général c'est à dire de la réduction
du temps de travail dans le secteur
marchand dans le secteur marchand le
bilan des 35 heures est au mieux
décevant au pire négatif il est décevant
si l'on considère le nombre d'emplois
créés tels étaient bien l'objet des lois
aubry lutter contre le chômage
créer de l'emploi en le partageant en
quelque sorte comme un gâteau
j'avais d'ailleurs à l'époque organisé à
l'assemblée nationale en tant que député
de la majorité de l'époque un colloque
que j'avais intitulé comment réussit à
des 35 heures donc esprit à la fois
critique et constructive déjà à l'issue
de nos travaux il ressortait un constat
partagé par la plupart des intervenants
et il y avait là martine aubry gilles de
robien des syndicalistes des
représentants du monde de l'économie et
nous partagions l'idée en tout cas la
plupart à savoir que la réduction du
temps de travail n'était pas une recette
miracle en matière de création d'emplois
au-delà de ces apports dans d'autres
domaines
et ce débat ce colloque s'était tenu
entre les deux lois et j'espérais à
l'époque en bon soldat ayant voté la loi
mais tout de même critique à bien des
égards infléchir le deuxième texte
rendre au fond la démarche concrète
pragmatique adaptée à la réalité
je vous dis ça pour dire je n'avais pas
d'à priori totalement négatif mais tout
de même une certaine prudence et
malheureusement cette démarche n'a pas
été écouté les 35 heures auraient en
effet je reviens au secteur marchand
créé 350 mille emplois le chiffre fait
consensus mais on est bien loin des
chiffres mirobolants cité par jean
arthuis est avancé par les promoteurs de
la réforme soit environ deux millions
d'emplois
le bilan est donc bien décevant en
revanche dans le même temps ce sont 650
mille emplois publics et parapublics qui
ont été en effet créé par la rtt presque
le double voilà qui est à la fois
frappants et instructif
au départ les 35 heures ne devait pas
être étendue à la fonction publique
c'est par décret et d'août 2000 qu'elles
l'ont été pourquoi pour des raisons
politiques bien sûr il y avait forcément
une demande qui s'étaient exprimées ici
ou là mais pas uniquement
les 35 heures ont aussi été étendue à la
fonction publique parce que le
gouvernement savait pertinemment que oui
dans ce secteur elle créerait de
l'emploi étendre la rtt à la fonction
publique était donc le seul moyen de
concrétiser un tant soit peu les
proposition mirifique de départ
autrement dit la rtt et principalement
un instrument de création d'emplois
publics et parapublics
en résumé le bilan plus que décevant
dans le secteur marchand et par ailleurs
une charge de personnel considérablement
accrue dans le secteur public
si à cela on ajoute des considérations
liées à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
le bilan pourrait passer le simplement
décevant a carrément négatif je parle au
conditionnel parce que l'impact négatif
de la rtt sur la compétitivité nationale
a certainement été quelque peu atténuée
par
la loi fillon d'assouplissement des 35
heures 17 janvier 2003 mais tout de même
les 35 heures créer un climat et
façonnent une image qui a d'évidence ne
joue pas en notre faveur dans tout cela
quelle est la problématique spécifique
de l'hôpital pas une problématique de
comptes de compétitivité bien entendu
mais une problématique beaucoup plus
simple d'effectifs et de coûte alors que
les enjeux de l'eau pitot ne sont pas
que celui là vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
les uns et les autres et gérard larcher
à l'instant avec la fougue qu'on lui
connaît c'est vrai qu'il ya d'autres
enjeux et que notre débat ne veut pas
être réducteur mais tout de même ça fait
partie du sujet problèmes d'effectif
d'abord c'est en 2002 qui a été
instaurée vous le savez la rtt dans les
hôpitaux le gouvernement jospin avait
promis la création de 3500 postes de
médecin de 45 mille postes on me dit qu
en fait c'est une partie de ces postes
ont été pourvus en effet si globalement
la fonction publique hospitalière a crû
de neuf cent trente mille à un million
cent trente mille soit plus de 21 8 5%
de 2000 à 2010 pour autant les
recrutements strictement médicaux ont
été insuffisants
le manque de personnel qualifié
l'infirmière par exemple n'a pas permis
à l'hôpital de s'adapter comme il le
fallait à la réforme
autrement dit la rtt a été imposée à
l'hôpital sans avoir été ni préparée ni
même accompagné aucun relèvement du
numerus clausus cette logique a généré
nombre de dysfonctionnements dans
l'organisation du travail à l'hôpital
de plus les crédits pour les postes
prévues ont souvent été gelés par les
hôpitaux en difficulté financière ce qui
m'amène à l'autre problème celui du coup
tu faute de pouvoir être remplacées de
nombreux médecins en cadres et cadres
ont été dans l'impossibilité de prendre
leurs jours
ils les ont stocké dans des comtés part
du temps qui au fil des ans n'ont cessé
de gonfler en 2012 on estimé que les
pâtes les praticiens quoi vous avez cité
le chiffre avait amassé environ 2
millions de jours
certains d'entre eux en avaient jusqu'à
150 ou 200 de leur côté personnels non
médicaux les personnels non médicaux
principalement les cadres avaient
accueilli un total d'environ 1,2 million
de jours parce que la loi de 2002
prévoyait que les jours ainsi stocker
devait être soldés dans sa les dix ans
un accord cadre a été conclu le 23
janvier 2012
entre les syndicats de praticiens et le
ministre de la santé de l'époque
d'accord imposé que les 20 premiers
jours stockés par un médecin soient pris
sous forme de congés
le reste devait être soldés dans un des
quatre ans le médecin a donc le choix
entre trois possibilités
d'abord primo il peut décider de prend
ses jours en projet mais dans ce cas
l'hôpital doit payer un remplaçant pour
faire tourner le service en tout cas
dans bien des cas secundo le médecin
peut opter pour des points retraite
supplémentaire mais là encore il ya un
coup de pot l'établissement qui doit
cotiser davantage au régime additionnel
de retraite des praticiens tertio le
médecin peut obtenir le paiement des
journaux pris dans ce cas chaque journée
lui est payé à hauteur de 300 euros par
seconde hôpital pour les personnels non
médicaux chaque journée est facturé à
hauteur de 180 euros dans tous les cas
de figure c'est à l'hôpital de payer
payer une politique de rtt qui n'a rien
à voir avec sa mission première
monsieur coûté bien sûr considérable il
a été évalué en 2012 à 600 millions mais
bien sûr le chiffre précis était
impossible à établir car dépendant des
choix des personnels concernés
à titre d'exemple pour l'hôpital de
mulhouse que je connais bien en tant que
président de son conseil de surveillance
depuis 25 ans le coot du compte épargne
temps est estimé à 18 millions d'euros
soit 5 % du budget total de l'hôpital de
360 millions d'euros
ça n'est pas rien voilà vous avez donc
pu suivre un débat sur la mise en place
des 35 heures à l'hôpital on se retrouve
à 15 heures pour les questions cribles